would you say it's basically something
that provides kind of an
all-encompassing system that works yes
when the bigger system doesn't yes and
sort of can replace yeah absolutely I'm
in the person that wrote this book as
owns a hookah said that bass that
basically the political has failed and
there are in the world at the moment
there are large number of cases where
what to Michael religious expectations
projected on to the political have
failed and the biggest one was the
Eastern European one and so on has to
club see the Eastern Orthodox revival in
that particular context but the idea
that redemption can comes through
politics when you see how that
particular version of politics is
actually worked out in practice that's
that's one element in the religious
revival the other is the one you've just
mentioned that where the hole is in a
state of collapse and it's basically
corrupt and kleptocratic then then a
smaller version which is completely
which is a complete environment if even
if there is some kleptocratic element in
its organization works